apex legend season 9 is just around the
corner and respawn has released new
details about the upcoming season's new
playable character
new weapon and new map changes before we
dive into everything consider
subscribing to the channel and leaving a
like
now let's get to it first up let's talk
about something
strange that could end up being really
cool apex legends next season
doesn't have a number associated with it
like season 4 assimilation or season 8
mayhem it's not season 9 legacy it's
just
called legacy or the legacy update in a
tweet apex legend senior writer tom
cassiello wrote and we doubled down on
that word legacy the legacies our
legends are inheriting the ones they're
leaving behind
so many surprises for lore hounds so
it's looking like this may not be a
traditional new season for apex legends
perhaps this will be a more
transformative update for the battle
royale something akin to season 3 when
we got a new map for the first time or
season 5 when we got quest for the first
time regardless the focus of the new
season is on the legacy of its
characters
and that's most apparent in the new
playable character shown in the stories
from the outlands north star trailer
their name is kairi imahara and they're
the daughter of viper one of the apex
predator pilots that you face in
titanfall 2.
kyrie goes by the callsign valkyrie
which we assume is their legend name
however a few respawn devs have referred
to them as simply bulk
whether that's shorthand for valkyrie or
the actual legends name has yet to be
confirmed for the purposes of this video
we're just going to use valkyrie
valkyrie is voiced by erica ishii who
you may know for their wonderful
performances as anna bray and destiny 2
maddie cho and marvel's avengers and
info flash host ruth in cyberpunk 2077.
we don't yet know what valkyrie's
abilities are but have a fairly good
idea thanks to a few clues and some good
old-fashioned deduction
in her character art valkyrie is wearing
a jet pack this tracks with the north
star trailer
in it we see rampart disassembling
viper's north star to build the jet pack
for his daughter specifically taking the
titan's vtol hoverkit
this is important viper doesn't fly
traditional northstar his north star is
outfitted with a specially modded v-tol
hoverkit that allows him to fly higher
longer and faster than your average
titan titanfall 2 fans will remember it
from a long
and difficult boss fight this likely
translates into valkyrie being the first
flight based legend with the capacity to
fly or
at least hover in the air and bombard
enemies from above
in the trailer celebrating apex legends
reaching 100 million players
we got our first glimpse at who we now
know is valkyrie
mirage looks up at a shadowy figure
jumping from a tower who then begins to
hover upwards
if we had to guess that's valkyrie's
passive ability we think that either her
jump is
naturally longer higher and takes her
further than other legends or that she
can choose to jump into a hover similar
to the titanfall 2 pilot hover perk
let's go back to her character art for
her tactical ability we see that her
jetpack is armed with the same launcher
that the north star titans use for their
cluster missile
she's even firing off rockets in the
picture respawn has taken inspiration
from a lot of titanfall pilot abilities
for apex legends it
stands to reason that the studio would
use titan abilities also
so valkyrie's tactical ability is
probably a cluster missile or
something similar to it in titanfall 2 a
cluster missile would explode into
several rockets on impact similar to how
fuse's knuckle cluster works but
a wider area of effect considering it is
the only northstar weapon specifically
designed to deal with enemy pilots as
opposed to titans it would make
sense that it's the weapon that valkyrie
chose to add to her kit
guessing valkyrie's ultimate ability is
trickier though
we don't have any more clues to really
go on it would certainly help if we knew
what kind of character she was our best
guess is either offense or recon
if valkyrie is an offense character then
maybe she pulls her ultimate ability
from another titan weapon
the north star's tether trap would be
cool but we wouldn't be opposed to nuke
eject either making valkyrie similar to
overwatch's diva however valkyrie is a
recon character then it makes more sense
that her ultimate ability would be
geared towards gathering information or
aiding her squad and moving across the
map
given she has viper's vitol hoverkit
maybe her ultimate ability allows her to
just
fly for a period of time giving her a
bird's eye view on the competition
or she may be able to bring her squad
mates with her so that they can redeploy
from any position
however without anything concrete from
respawn this is
all speculation on our part first off
we're getting a new weapon the beaucheck
bow
it is the first non-traditional firearm
added to the game and describing the bow
respawn writes a powerful and deadly
weapon for those with the skill to wield
it capable of inflicting tremendous
damage at medium range you'll need to
make each shot count
respawn hasn't made any indication as to
what type of
ammo the nubo takes our go-to response
would be to say that the bow is a care
package item and thus it doesn't need to
have an
ammo type you'll just have a set amount
of arrows when you loot it
but apex legends design director jason
mccord teasingly tweeted
arrows aren't an ammo type have you
played season nine
so maybe we're getting a new aero ammo
type in legacy which would be huge
considering a new ammo type hasn't been
added since season four
on top of all that olympus is finally
getting a major map change the only one
of the three maps to have not undergone
a change yet olympus is going to get
infested an infestation has sprung loose
strangling the city with roots and
natural growths respawn writes
that could be what we saw a glimpse of
in the 100 million player celebration
trailer we mentioned earlier
a few shots showcase a map that looks
like olympus but has
way too much nature which made us
theorize it was either king's canyon
world's edge or a brand new area for an
entirely brand new mode
but maybe that's just our first glimpse
at an olympus infested
and on top of all of that something else
is coming we don't know what yet but
respawn director of communication ryan
rigney cryptically tweeted that
in one week we'll update the site with
one more pretty huge thing
so looks like on april 26th we're in
store to hear about
one more giant change coming to apex
legends
perhaps it relates back to the nugget of
information apex legends game director
chad grineer told us at the start of
season 8
when he said that respawn wants to do
something similar to season 5's ppe
quest again or maybe this new thing is
connected to a different comment from
grineer where he said later this year
respawn will launch new ways to play the
game
that take us beyond battle royale what
do you think it is
legacy is giving us a new character
weapon and map already so
what could this other big edition be
leave your guesses in the comments below
be sure to subscribe to stay up to date
on more apex legends
we'll meet you for the drop when apex
legends legacy begins on may 4th
you